and now the big big big won best picture
of the year
somewhere out there 5/10 nervous
producers and from what I know of
producers they're biting each other's
nails to present the award here's one of
the fairest ladies of them all Miss
Julie Andrews
pretty thank you before I read the
nominations Bob may I say just a word
well it's getting late June I know I
know but I did want to express the
admiration for us all for the manner in
which you've conducted this program
tonight such ease such wit such take
your time Julie but you were you just
told me to hurry mom we keep going I'll
see if I can cut a commercial okay we've
seen excerpts from the five films
nominated for Best Picture for the
record they are Bonnie and Clyde a
two-tier ahilla production Warner
Brothers seven arts Warren Beatty
producer dr. Dolittle AB Jack
productions 20th Century Fox
Arthur P Jacobs producer the Graduate a
Mike Nichols Lawrence terman production
embassy Lawrence terman producing guess
who's coming to dinner
Columbia Stanley Kramer producer and in
the heat of the night the nourish
corporation production United Artists
Walter Mirage producer and now for the
best picture may I have the envelope
please
thank you the winner is in the heat of
the night
thank you thank you members of the
Academy from it's very inception in the
heat of the night has been a labor of
love for all those of us who've been
part of it and I want to express my deep
gratitude to all of the talented artists
who contributed to it but most
particularly to my friend partner Norman
Jewison whose brilliant Direction
brought it so vividly to life
we are all very grateful for your
recognition of our efforts and for your
recognition of the lesson of in the heat
of the night thank you
well that's about it ladies and
gentlemen for the winners it's a better
roses for the rest of us it's back to
our gurus and abettor names I hope that
the program tonight has been as exciting
and as fascinating for you as it has
been for me I've never seen six hours
was by so fast you know Oscar certainly
has grown in the last 40 years he made
his first appearance at a banquet at the
Coconut Grove it was a private party for
a small group of picture makers today he
belongs as much to you the audiences
around the world as he does to us
whereas he has grown so as our industry
and with growth comes responsibility
movies progressed from being just
entertainment to one of our most
meaningful art forms the art form that
most truly reflects today's work it's
turmoils its dreams its anguish and
expectations the old cliches that long
dominated the screen such as the good
Cowboys versus the bad Indians the pure
unsullied heroine untouched by human
hand or reality the prince charming
strong chivalrous incorruptible and
totally unbelievable the foreigner
inevitably typecast as the villain all
these have been discarded and replaced
by people with weaknesses as well as
strengths defeats as well as triumphs in
short films today more accurately
reflect the human condition no longer do
we portray the world as we wish it was
today we show the world as it is perhaps
tomorrow we will depict the world as it
could be the Zucker's the gold ones the
Warner's the men who began our industry
had at least one thing in common with a
man from Atlanta they had a dream that
has taken time but the dreams of the
merchants and the martyr have began the
merge if not out of idealism then out of
necessity another martyr said it all
united we stand divided we fall
rioting and indifference are equal sins
everyone was faced up to their
responsibilities no one person no one
industry no one race or creed can
conquer bigotry find human understanding
or unite us all in a brother
the peace and love it's a challenge that
each of us must face in our own way
through our own way of life in our own
station it is a challenge we must and we
will meet good night
you
richard burton and gene simmons star in
a special Easter Sunday presentation of
the road see this inspiring and
beautiful motion picture classic Sunday
night at 8:00 in color here on ABC